early morning in South Manchester and a
prolific burglar known to the police
arrested for a Spate of sets
a search of the property and officers
bagged enough evidence to charge this
man for stealing from student
accommodations a rare success
but as they detained one criminal others
were set to work
just minutes away two males broke into a
family home stealing both cars off the
driveway
and in line with the Force's commitment
to attend every burglary call introduced
last year so they've snapped the lock
from there officers were deployed
quickly to carry out a full
investigation
this street is familiar to Greater
Manchester police over the last six
weeks alone they've seen three
burglaries with cars stolen from
driveways it's a crime that is common
but despite the Swift response from
police catching the criminals isn't
just five percent of cases reported in
Greater Manchester end up with a suspect
being brought to court leaving many
cases unsolved but in the last 12 months
since making time to respond to every
incident they've seen an increase of
arrest by 52 percent we need to get that
public confidence back so we're working
hard to improve all the basic standards
of getting to getting to see someone
when they're when they are burgled
having a a police officer attending
during a thorough investigation and then
tying up all those links using Partners
so we've got a proper outcome for the
victim the force says it still needs to
do more but Manchester's model of
attending every burglary will for the
first time be adopted by police Chiefs
across the country even though it could
present resourcing issues so it is going
to be a challenge particularly in larger
urban areas but it's the right thing to
do police forces have to make choices
and they make choices every day on what
the priorities are going to be and
police Chiefs have now made is a
priority they have collectively agreed
that they will meet this challenge
this is a crime deeply invasive and
often terribly traumatic the anguish of
a case unsolved only adds to it and with
pressure mounting on police to improve
their response it's hope this Landmark
agreement will bring about change into
memory sheet Sky News greater Manchester